el pueblo ha hablado Trump será
reintegrado vox populi Box day con estas
palabras el nuevo jefe de Twitter elan
más que anunció el regreso de Donald
Trump a la red social poco antes más que
había lanzado una encuesta entre sus
seguidores sobre el tema más de 15
millones de personas respondieron y el
51,8% votó a favor de retorno del
expresidente a la plataforma pero si
bien Trump dijo que con más Twitter está
en buenas manos también declaró que se
quedaría en su red Truth social
Bueno me gusta que haya comprado Twitter
y las más siempre me ha gustado pero
tengo algo llamado Truth social Es
realmente fantástico
Trump fue expulsado de Twitter en enero
de 2021 después de que sus partidarios
asaltaran el Capitolio en Washington el
entonces jefe de estado había sido
acusado de incitar a la violencia y lo
más multimillonario propietario de tesla
spacex se hizo cargo de la red a finales
de octubre desde entonces restableció
varias cuentas suspendidas en nombre de
la libertad de expresión y sus
decisiones no han dejado de crear
polémica para tranquilizar a los
anunciantes principal fuente de ingresos
del grupo El Ejecutivo aseguró que no se
tomaría ninguna decisión importante
sobre los contenidos o la reactivación
de cuentas sin la intervención de un
consejo específico sin embargo no
específico si este consejo había sido
creado